-Well, you guys, last night,
the Jets lost to the Brown
on Monday Night Football 23-3.
And it was embarrassing
and hard to watch,
just like Sean Spicer
on "Dancing with the Stars."
It was --
You guys see this? Last night,
Sean Spicer made his debut
on "Dancing with the Stars,"
and everyone was talking
about his outfit.
Take a look at this.
Ooh, man.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like your fun aun
after three wine coolers.
You know what I'm saying?
He looks like
the puffy shirt from "Seinfeld
had sex with a glow stick.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Spicer's shirt
actually went viral,
and I think one guy is jealous
of all the attention,
'cause it's the only way
to explain this.
I mean, that's --
-Oh, wow.
-He shouldn't be doing it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right,
Sean Spicer made his debut
on "Dancing with the Stars
last night.
It was so bad,
the judges actually
turned their chairs around
like "The Voice."
-Really?
-They didn't even care, yeah
They're changing the rules
A lot of people weren't happ
that Spicer was given a spot
on "Dancing with the Stars
due to his role
in the Trump Administration.
Yeah, we got to be careful
or we'll tarnish
the great American institution
"Dancing with the Stars."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news here.
Last night, Trump held a rally
in New Mexico,
and he tried to say the name
of a county in New Mexico,
Doña Ana, but struggled quit
a bit with the pronunciation
Check it out.
-The Donana --
[ Laughter ]
On the border, commissioner --
-That's right.
Next thing Trump said was,
[As Trump]
"This place is Donanas.
D-O-N-A-N-A.
♪♪ This place is
Donanas, D-O-N-A-N-A ♪♪
♪♪ This place is Donanas,
D-O-N-A-N-A-S ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What else? What else do I got?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ Donana, ooh na-na ♪♪
♪♪ I will deport you
from Donana, ooh na-na ♪♪
Come on."
[ Normal voice ] But today Trump
held a fundraiser in Californi
where he has some of
his worst approval ratings
And it's bad.
When Trump rode by Disneyland,
Mickey Mouse said if he had
middle finger, he'd be using it.
-Really?
-I go, yeah.
[ As Mickey Mouse ]
"I'd do it again, I don't care."
[ Laughter ]
2020 news last night.
Elizabeth Warren
held a massive rally
right here in New York City.
It was a crazy scene.
Check out the scene.
That was -- Yeah.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right,
Warren was so popular,
the only way police could ge
everyone to leave was by saying,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
New York City Mayor
Bill de Blasio."
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're running away!
There's no one here! Oh, my God.
That was fast.
[ Laughter ]
And Warren wasn't
the only Democrat in the park.
Bernie Sanders was also ther
on a bench feeding the pigeons
and muttering to himself,
[As Sanders] "The top 1%
get all the bread crumbs.
The top 1% get
all the bread crumbs!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Some TV news --
Netflix just purchased
the exclusive streaming rights
to "Seinfeld"
for over $500 million.
[ Audience "ooh"s ]
Fans heard that and were like,
"Finally, a place to watch
'Seinfeld' on TV."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, NBC just announce
their new streaming servic
called Peacock.
-Whoo!
If you want more --
If you want more information
just Google "pea-cock"
and "stream,"
and that should be
the first thing...
[ Laughter ]
...that comes up.
♪♪♪♪
-Streaming.
[ Laughter ]
-Get this --
Tinder just announced
that it will be making
its own TV show.
-Ooh.
-It's a tough show to cast
'cause everyone who auditioned
looked nothing like
their head shot.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Tinder is gettin
into scripted television.
Today, they even announced their
new series, "Law & Order: STD.
[ "Law & Order" theme sound
We have a great show!